المترجم: Yomna Elhaddad
المدقّق: Eman Sabry
مساء الخير!
حركة مكعب الروبيك.
أريد أن أحدثكم عن فكرة
حركة مكعب روبيك السحري.
وأتمنى أن يكون ما سأقوله الآن
مُثبت ومعروف من قبل.
أول شيء، الروبيك هو ببساطة
مكعب نستخدمه كلعبة،
وتحتاج فقط أن يكون
لكل الجوانب نفس اللون.
هذه هي وظيفته.
ومثل الكثير من الاختراعات
تم تسميته تيمناً بمبتكره.
كان ذلك المخترع أستاذاً جامعياً،
كان مهندساً،
أراد أن يوضح فكرة إلى الطلاب.
فى عام 1974، قام إرنو روبيك
باختراع المكعب.
وكان الغرض منه توصيل معلومة
وليس مجرد لعبة.
ما الذي أراد فعله؟
أراد أن يخبر الناس أنه من الممكن
تغيير تركبيب أي جسم،
بدون تحريك الجسم كله.
وهذا ما يحدث فعلاً
تقوم بتحريك جانب واحد،
لكن هناك جانبان لا يزالان كما هما.
هذا هو الهدف وتلك هي الفكرة
التي أراد إيصالها.
لكن بعد ذلك، أصبح لعبه تُصنَع،
وبدأ الناس يعرفونه على أنه مجرد لعبة.
منذ عام 1974 حتى 2009.
كان مصنفاً كلعبة وبيع منه عدد كبير.
وفي عام 2009 وصل عدد المبيعات
إلى 350 مليون مكعب.
ولكنني شخص يحب المقارنات.
وأريد أن أعرف ما الذي يرمز له ذلك الرقم.
في عام 2009، كان ال350 مليوناً رقماً
أكبر من عدد السكان في كل الدول العربية.
350 مليون لعبة!
حسناً، ما التالي؟
أيضاً عام 2009،
كان ال350 مليوناً أكبر
من عدد مستخدمي الإنترنت
الموجودين في كل هذه الأماكن
وليس مكاناً واحداً.
لقد بيع منه عدد كبير.
دعونا ننظر إلى المكعب بطريقة مختلفة،
لدى المكعب العديد من التركيبات،
وبإمكانك الوصول إلى العديد من الإحتماليات
وهي ببساطة: 18ˆ10×43.
18ˆ10 هو مليار المليار.
رقم كبير جداً وهو يُدعى
بالكوينتيليون في اللغة الإنجليزية.
الكوينتيليون رقم ضخم!
والـ43 كوينتيليون أكبر من المسافة
التي يقطعها الضوء خلال مئة عام.
عدد كبير جداً من الإحتماليات!
يكاد لا يوجد شيء يمتلك
ذلك العدد من الإحتماليات.
لكن أود إخباركم أنه هنالك شيئًأ
يمتلك عدداً أكبر من الإحتماليات،
ألا وهي حياتك.
بها إحتماليات أكبر من تلك،
كيف؟ دعونا نرى.
لو اعتبرنا أن حياتك هي مجموعة القرارت
التي تقوم باتخاذها وأنت على قيد الحياة.
فلديك العديد من القرارات
التي تحدد المسار الذي ستسلكه.
دعونا نأخذ مثالاً عن شخص سيعيش 60 عاماً.
ويمر خلالها بالعديد من المراحل.
حسناً.
لو افترضنا أنه في كل يومِ
سيتخذ قراراً واحداً فقط لا غير،
وهذا أمر شبه مستحيل.
لأنك تتخذ قراراً أثناء عبور الشارع.
وتناولك الطعام في منزلك
أم في الخارج يُعد قراراً.
استيقاظك من النوم وإمساكك للهاتف
أم غسل وجهك يُعد قراراً.
فاتخاذك قرار واحد في اليوم أمر مستحيل.
لكننا سنفترض أن شخص سيعيش لمدة 60 عاماً،
سيأخذ قراراً واحداً في اليوم
وسينتج عن كل قرارِ اثنان من النتائج.
وبالطبع كل نتيجة ستؤدي إلى قرار آخر.
لكننا سنثبت عند هذا الاقتراح.
ستأخذ قرارًا واحداً في اليوم لمدة 60 سنة،
وسيؤدي كل قرار تأخذه لطريقين.
أتعرفون كم سيكون عدد الإحتماليات؟
رقم مهول!
أكبر بكثير من ال43 كوانتليون
الخاصة بالمكعب.
وهذا بالفعل مثال عملي،
أن الاحتماليات الكثيرة تلك الخاصة بالمكعب.
لدى الحياة احتماليات أكبر منها بكثير.
أريد أن أتحدث معكم في نقطة.
لدينا الآن ...
ما دمت أمتلك العديد من القرارات،
التي تحدد اتجاهاتي
علي أن أبدأ بالفلترة، لماذا؟
حتى لا أصبح نسخة، حتى أصبح مختلفاً.
يختلف بعض الناس عن الآخرين
في أنهم لا يسيرون وراء نفس الهدف.
فلابد لي من الفلترة،
ما دامت هذه القرارات تحدد اتجاهاتي.
ما دام لدي احتماليات غير محدودة،
أو رقم محدود لكنه كبير جداً.
لذا عليَ فلترة القرارات
حتى أرى إلي أي طريق ستأخذني.
حسناً.
أود اليوم ببساطة أن أقارن
هذا المكعب بحياتك.
حتى نرى ما هي الاحتماليات أو الخيارات
التي من الممكن أن تكون موجودة
في كلا المكعب وحياتك، حسناً.
أول شيء موجود سنتكلم عنه هو
أنك تستخدم هذا المكعب كلعبة،
لكن للعبة هدف.
تخيل أنك وصلت لجانب ذي لون واحد.
من برأيه يظن أنني انتهيت؟!
فليرفع يده!
من يرى أنني لم أنتهي بعد؟!
لم أنتهي، لأن هدفي هو إنهاء المكعب كله.
هذا ما يحدث بالضبط
أثناء القرارت التي أتخذها.
لا يجب عليَ أن أكون سعيداً
من الإنجاز الأول.
لابد لي من الإنتظار والسؤال،
أهذا حقاً ما كنت أطمح في الوصول إليه؟
أم أنها نتيجة خادعة؟
ليست النتيجة المثالية
التي أرغب في الوصول إليها.
فبالتالي، عليك النظر إلى الصورة الكاملة.
ليس مجرد إنتهائك من جانب واحد
يعني أنك قد إنتهيت كُلياً.
لا، انظر أولاً إلي هدفك
ثم إلى الصورة كاملة بعدها.
حسناً.
الشيء الثاني، عندما أُمسك بهذا المكعب،
أشعر أنه يمثل تحدياً.
أشعر بالتحدي والرغبة في الوصول إلى ألوانه.
وهذا هو التحدي الموجود.
وفي نفس الوقت،
لديك العديد من التحديات في حياتك
وهي غير معدودة.
وليس شرطاً أن تكون مشتركة.
لكنني سأتكلم عن بعض التحديات
التي من الممكن أن تكون مشتركة.
حسناً.
أول تحديٍ من البداية منذ
أن كنت صغيرًا هو المذاكرة
مهما كنت تدرس، مهما كان موقفك،
المذاكرة هي دائما ما تكون تحدياً.
وعندما تصل لمرحلة أعلى عندما تكبر،
قيادة السيارة تصبح تحدياً،
وتصبح مشكلة كبيرة.
وفي مرحلة أخرى، عندما تعيش وحيداً
يصبح الطبخ تحدياً بالنسبة إليك.
التحدي موجود، أياً كان تأثيره في الشخص
وعندما تكبر، ستشعر أن وقتك يمثل تحدياً.
ستشعر كما لو كنت تجري حول نفسك.
لديك موعد للتسليم النهائي في الجامعة،
لديك موعد للتسليم النهائي في العمل.
أنا مرتبط بالعديد من الأشياء،
وأجري حول نفسي.
وأصبح الوقت تحدياً.
بدأت أشعر بقيمة هذا الوقت.
وهذا تحدي.
وبعد ذلك، سيأتي موضوع الوظيفة.
فعلًا الوظيفة، بغض النظر عن المكان
أو البلد، تشكل تحدياً.
لماذا؟ لأنك تعلم ومتأكد
أنهم سيقومون بفلترة الناس.
وتخاف في داخلك ألا تكون ملائماً.
فهذا تحدي.
حتى فيما بعد وأنت في الوظيفة
ربما تشعر أن هذا المكان
ليس مناسباً بالنسبة لك.
تشعر في داخلك بوجود مشكلة.
فجزء الوظيفة يشكل جزءاً كبيرًا في حياتنا.
وبالفعل يمثل تحدياً.
ماذا أيضاً يؤثر بنا؟
في وقت من الأوقات،
ربما تشعر أن المال يمثل تحدياً
أي كان حبك أو كرهك لهذا المبدأ
لكنه بالفعل تحدي، ربما تحتاج لشيء
ولا يمكنك الوصول إليه
والسبب الوحيد هو المال.
وهذا هو التحدي.
وبعد ذلك، هناك الأشياء العاطفية،
التحديات العاطفية التي تمر بالشباب.
فعلى سبيل المثال،
عندما تكون معجباً بشخص ما،
يصبح تحدياً لك، لابد أن يعجبه كل ما تقول
ولابد أن يقربك إليه كل ما تفعل
ولا يبعدك عنه.
لهذا وأنت لا تدري، تضع نفسك تحت ضغط رهيب
أو تحدٍ كبير حتى تصل إلى هذا الشخص.
ربما ننظر لهذا الأمر على أنه فكاهه.
لكنه يحدث معك ومعي ومع غيرنا.
حتى لو أردت أن تنكره، لكنه موجود بالفعل.
تقول الأبحاث أن من أصعب التحديات
العاطفية أن تكون في علاقة،
أو تسعي إليها، هذا شيء موجود.
وتزداد التحديات العاطفية عندما تفقد شخصاً.
وهذا سيحدث عاجلاً أم آجلاً.
سأفقد شخصاً من أصدقائي أو عائلتي
ربما حدث هذا بالفعل وربما لا.
لكنها حقائق، ولا بد لنا
أن نعرف أنها قد تحدث الآن،
أو بعد يوم أو سنة،
وهذه هي التحديات.
وماذا أيضاً؟
المرحلة الأخيرة هي بعد أن تكبر،
بعض الناس يصبح التحدي بالنسبة
إليهم هو أن لا يمكنهم
النهوض من السرير والسير
حتى الدور الأول أو إلى الشارع.
ففي مرحلة من حياتنا سيصل
بنا التحدي إلى هذا المستوى.
أنه لا يمكنك رفع سماعة الهاتف
والاتصال بأحدهم لأنك متعب.
هنالك مشكلةٌ في حياتك.
هذا هو تحدٍ، ربما تمر به وربما لا.
لهذا أرى أن المكعب يمثل تحدياً،
وفي نفس الوقت
هنالك الكثير من التحديات في حياتنا.
لذلك قمت باختيار الأشياء المشتركة.
لكن هناك أشياء لا تحدث مع كل الناس
هناك تحديات غير ما سبق وقد
لا تحدث مع كل الناس.
سأعطي لكم مثالاً:
الناس الذين يعيشون
في المناطق الجليدية (الإسكيمو).
حسناً، كم تعريف لدينا عن الثلج؟
إننا نسميه بالثلج،
لا يوجد لدينا تعريف آخر.
لكن لدى هؤلاء الناس 30 تعريفاً للثلج.
لماذا؟ لأن تحديه اليومي
هو أن يدوس علي هذه البقعة،
وهو يثق أنها صلبة ومستقرة ولن تهوي به.
هذا النوع مختلف وهذا نوع ثالث
يمكنني المشي عليه لمدة ثانية أو اثنين
لكن عليَ ألا أمشي على النوع الرابع.
فالتحدي اليومي لهذا الرجل
أن يحسب كل خطوة يقوم بها.
لدي هؤلاء الناس 30 نوعاً من الثلج.
حسناً.
أود أن أشارك معكم تحدياً أو قصة حدثت معي.
كنت يوماً ما في ألمانيا
وطرق أحدهم الباب عليَ،
استيقظت من النوم هكذا ونظرت إلى الساعة
فوجدت أنها الثالثة فجراً.
فتحت الباب ووجدت شخصاً أمامي غارقاً في دمه
الأرض تغطيها الدماء.
ويقول لي بمنتهى البساطة:
هل لك أن تفتح لي الباب؟
لم أكن أعرف ما الذي علي
فعله في هذا الموقف.
أول شيء، لقد استيقظت بهذا المنظر
والأرض غارقة بالدم أمامي.
فكان الأمر صعباً.
أول تحدِ هنا، أن الرجل كان
بحاجة إلى العلاج الطبي.
وفي ألمانيا غير مسموح لك
أن تقدم العلاج إن لم تكن مخولاً بذلك.
فهذا هو التحدي، هل سأقوم بمداواته
وفعل أي شيء أم أتركه كما هو؟
المجازفة وراء هذا التحدي،
أنه من الممكن للرجل
أن يستيقظ في اليوم التالي،
ويظن أنني فعلت هذا له،
لأنه لم يكن بوعيه الليلة الماضية
ويسبب لي مشكلة.
فهذا تحدٍ، حالات تحدث،
والتحديات التي تحدث في حياتنا
تختلف من شخصٍ لآخر.
نعود إلي المكعب وحياتك.
نأخذ مثالاً آخر مشترك في الاثنين.
ألابد لي أن أكون نسخة ممن سبقوني؟
في المكعب، هذا ممكن ولما لا؟
أريد أن أعرف كيف تنهي أول مرحلة،
وأنا سأستمر بعدها وأنهي المكعب كله.
لا يوجد مشكلة، هذا أمر جيد.
قبل أن يقوم العالم بتنفيذ فكرته،
يقوم بالإطلاع على من سبقوه.
ويكمل من بعدهم
فهذا ليس أمراً خاطئاً.
لكن لو أصبح أسلوب حياتك كله هكذا،
ستصبح نسخة من غيرك.
خذ ما في يدك وابنِ عليه
لكن لا تصبح مجرد ناسخ،
تنسخ وتقلد وتنسخ وتقلد،
لابد أن تظهر قراراتك وشخصيتك.
وليس معنى الظهور أن يشير الناس عليك،
بل أن تكون لك شخصيتك الخاصة.
فالنسخ في حالة المكعب قد يجدي نفعاًً،
لكن النسخ في الحياة ربما يفيد،
لكن ليس بالشكل المبالغ فيه.
حتى لا تصبح نسخة مكررة من شخص آخر.
حسناً، ما التالي؟
لو لديَ قواعد...
كسر القواعد...
لو لديَ هذا المكعب لكنني فشلت،
ما الذي سأفعله؟
سأحطمه، وألصق الألوان بعضها إلى جانب بعض
وأعطيه لشخص وأخبره أنني أنهيته.
ما رأيك؟
ألم ينتهي؟ لقد انتهي،
والألوان كلها تشبه بعضها
لكن لو أتى ليأخذ مني المكعب
ووقع على الأرض،
ما الذي سيحدث حينها؟
سيتحطم، لأنني فككته من الأساس
وقمت بإعادة لصقه، لتظهر النتيجة النهائية.
وفي نفس الوقت لا يمكنك كسر القواعد
في الكثير من الأشياء في حياتك.
ليس لأن أحداً شاهدك وسيشير إليك،
بل لأن نتيجته لن تكون مستقرة.
لن تكون شيئاً ثابتاً
قد تبني عليها شيءُ فيما بعد.
كالمكعب، بمجرد أن مسكته
ووقع علي الأرض تحطم!
فلابد للعملية التي تقوم بها
أن تكون مستقرة.
لا تنسخ أحداً ولا تكسر القواعد
من الممكن أن تصل بطريقة أخرى،
حتي لو رأيت أن المشاكل مختلفة.
حسناً، ما التالي؟
هل الهدف المثالي أن تنهي المكعب؟
أجل، هذا هدف أرغب بالوصول إليه.
لكن في حياتك، هل من المثالية
أن تعرف كل شيء؟
لا، ليس شرطاً.
هناك أشياء ترغب في معرفتها،
حاول واعرف عنها.
هناك العديد من الأشياء ستمر
أمامك ولا نعرف لها معنى
ولا يمكننا الوصول إليها،
هذه ليست مشكلة.
لكن لا داعي للتدقيق.
لا أقصد أن تكون شخصاً عشوائياً،
تمر الأمر ولا تفهم الدنيا.
لكن لو وضعت في عقلك أن عليك
فهم كل شيء من الألف إلى الياء.
بكل تفاصيلها، ستتعب.
هي ليست كالمكعب الذي ترغب في إنهائه.
لا يجب عليك إنهاؤه.
عليك أن تفعل ما تريد أن تصل إليه.
انظر إلي أين ترغب في الوصول
وابنٍ على هذا الأساس.
لكن لو وضعت هدفاً أن تنهي المكعب
إلى آخره، ستتعب قليلاً.
لماذا؟ لأن ليس كل شيء نصل إليه،
هناك من يموت قبل الوصول إلى هدفه.
أبإمكاننا أن نقول عنه إنه رجل سيء؟
لا، لقد حاول هذا الرجل
أي كانت الخطوة التي وقف عندها.
لا يجب عليك إنهاء المكعب.
لا يجب أن تصل إلى معنى كل شيء في حياتك.
حتى لا تتعب، لا يجب عليك
التدقيق في كل شيء.
الرجل الذي اخترغ هذا المكعب
(إرنو روبيك)،
يقول أن المشكلة في هذا المكعب تعتمد عليك.
بالفعل من الممكن أن تمسك أنت ومن بجانبك
نفس المكعب بنفس التركيبات،
تبدآن مع بعضكما لكنك تنتهي وهو لا.
لماذا؟ لأن المشكلة تعتمد عليك.
لا تحسب أن المشكلة هي نهاية الطريق، لا.
تقول لك المشكلة: هيا أرني ما ستقوم بفعله.
هذه طريقة!
لقد مسكت المكعب وكان هدفي
ببساطة أن أقارنه بالحياة.
وقد وجدت العديد من الأشياء المشتركة بينهما
وهناك المزيد، لكن هذا
ما تمكنت من الوصول والتفكير به.
لهذا أريد منكم أن تفكروا،
ما هو الشيء الذي يمكن أن يكون
مشتركاً بين هذا وذاك.
ما الشيء الذي قد ينفع في الاثنين،
وتخبروني هذا الشيء موجود في المكعب،
وموجود في الحياة.
وسيسعدني أن أستقبل ردودكم أو أفكاركم
عن الشيء المشترك بين المكعب والحياة.
لو أردتم أن تكتبوا لي أي شيء سيسعدني جداً.
لأنني أحب التفكير في الأشياء المشتركة
أُدعى مينا رأفت وأنا سعيد أنني كنت معكم.
في حركة مكعب روبيك.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)